[Music]
[ __ ] tops it
we're still 18 years
why would he they responded to a robbery
people gonna rob 660 pounds of coke did
you drive a BMW door to the job you
bring just one other guy with you and
you only take 50 keys this is a big dumb
lock all set up
to shoot us automatic weapons
seconds attila together
and refused
to allow these families to be
traumatized with trials and appeals and
parole hearings I'm asking you to
protect them from that I understand
everything about these guys has been
confident so far
close the island what island been had
there 21 bridges and shut them down
three rivers closing yeah a version of
this where these two are found
none of this makes sense because it is
more - this whole thing is filthy
what's going on here consumer trying to
see how
whose cops live at the city that
actively dislikes them listen they still
protect with their lives I just need the
truck you go down this road you're on
your own
you do wrong the afraid but he does not
bear the sword in vain the very top arm
belongs [ __ ] fingers over your head
I will find you
[Music]
[Music]
you